Wow!
Good morning!
Good morning everybody!
Hello, hello!
Okay, I hope she doesn't start while I'm doing my intro.
So, Edelian has requested me to not show any of the audio or the visuals of their debut.
So, you'll have to click on the link if you want to see what I'm watching.
Anyway, it was so last minute.
They literally contacted me, I think like two or three days ago.
I don't remember.
I just remember like one of my staff like just messaged me about it.
And then I was like, oh, I haven't really done like something like this before.
I figured like, to be fair, okay.
They offered a lot of money and I was like, because it's sponsored.
I was just like, you know what?
I mean...
I can use this to reinvest in my channel.
I can use this to like reinvest into Doki Bird, into my channel.
And like into like stuff for you, Dragoons.
And I'm, oh my gosh.
I just, I can't spoil anything.
But I've been...
There's a lot of projects down the line that require a lot of funding.
So, I was like, oh, okay.
This would be good.
Oh, shit.
She's starting.
Okay.
I haven't done one of these in a long time.
I haven't watched a fucking full debut in a very long time.
Oh, it started.
Funding secured.
True.
Oh, they're using the AI.
AI voice.
Okay.
She's like a, she's like a fireman.
The text-to-speech.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna lie.
From all the like ads with that exact voice.
Like my first instinct is to flee, you know, like the flight or flight or fight.
Every time I hear, hear that voice that like text-to-speech voice.
I was like flight.
Yeah.
We will.
Okay.
You know, what's funny.
I'm so sorry.
I'm talking over your deep.
Ever since like, ever since like, uh, the, like, uh, the idol EN sponsored watch along news broke out.
I got a lot of companies reaching out to me because it like opened the fucking dam.
A lot of companies started reaching out.
Asking if I would want to do like a, do like an official watch alongs and stuff like that.
And then like, um, my staff, one of my staff members was like, yeah, like we, we were after your, after like that tweet went public, a lot of companies reached out.
I was like, oh shit.
And then obviously I'm not going to take every offer.
This was like, I was, uh, I was like the first one to reach out.
So I was just like, yeah, yeah, I can do it.
I mean, they're offering a lot.
So I might as well.
Unless, unless the company gives me a lot of money.
I won't be accepting all of them.
Toki's doing sponsored watch along.
Let's fucking go.
Oh my gosh.
All her assets are really pretty though.
Oh no.
The shorts meta.
I like how she used a fucking fake PNG.
You're now the advertising meta.
Book your Toki bird today.
No, I'm like a cameo.
I'm literally cameo.
Oh my gosh.
Her ears move.
Her ears are like dog ears.
You're saying fucking vertical streamers.
Wait.
Is she using like those?
Those like pre subtitles?
Wait.
Oh no.
Whoa.
She timed those.
Wait.
I can't tell if those are like, I can't tell if those subtitles are like AI generated.
Not AI.
Is it like those like those translating ones where you talk and then the subtitles show up?
Or like she fucking timed the subtitles perfectly.
The last subtitles.
I can't tell.
I don't know if that was like generated or not.
That was actually crazy.
I know there's like one for like Japanese as well.
Like Japanese live translation.
That's something.
There's something not generated.
I can't watch two streams at once on mobile.
It feels bad, man.
They're like apparently, Encore is apparently like an idol.
An idol.
Idol.
Group.
An idol.
Idol.
Group.
I think it's like their first one.
So they're all like technically singers.
They're actually.
Oh no.
That's the singing.
But apparently they're like made just for singing.
So like they're all should be like really good singers.
Technically.
Wait.
What?
Yeah.
Like actually idol focused.
Free entertainment.
Let's go for free concert for free.
I love free concerts.
I can't believe it.
They paid me to watch a concert.
It's great.
Also guys, you guys don't know.
I'm only watching one stream.
I'm so busy.
This was supposed to be a rest week.
And then, thank God, okay, not thank God that it's like, she's like scuffed a little.
But at least I can talk a little bit more to you guys.
I can give more announcements while she's figuring stuff out.
Not thank God for her, but it gives me time to give you guys announcements while she sets everything up.
Anyway, this week was supposed to be...
This week was supposed to be rest week, but so many things came up last minute.
Dang Toki.
I'm so busy.
How considerate of her, that she lets me like, do my nows me.
What?
I'm just listening to the lyrics and I'm like, what?
Why is this?
Like, why?
It is white boy rap!
This rap is too lit for Old Lady Toki!
No!
What are you talking about?
Is this what zoomers listen to now?
Is this what zoomers listen to?
Of course this is what zoomers listen to.
I'm a zoomer, right?
Wait, is this... okay.
Is this an original rap?
Or like, is she doing a cover?
Are these real lyrics?
There's no way she's freestyling this, right?
There's no way!
The lyrics, like, sort of made sense from the ones that I could, like, figure out.
Toki's in her 60s, Toki Beach!
I am ageless!
Anime women do not age!
I'll forever be hit with the times!
She's coming after Drake next.
I heard there was, like, some fucking Drake vs.
Kendrick Lamar drama.
And, like, honestly, I have not been paying any attention to, like, pop culture since becoming an...
Well, to be fair, I only... I only, like...
absorbed the stuff that shows up on Twitter.
But then when I heard about the Drake vs.
Kendrick Lamar drama, I was like, Drake?
The fucking Canadian boy?
That guy... that guy is, like... that guy is, like, fucking...
Like, nobody takes him seriously.
From Degrassi?
Yeah!
That's, like, the Degrassi dude?
The guy that was in the wheelchair?
The guy from the meme?
Oh, this is, like, her trailer... her, like, info trailer.
Drake, the famous explorer.
No, nobody will ever forget that he was on Degrassi.
I feel like debut streams is always so nerve-wracking.
Obviously, because it's, like, you know, it's, like, the first impression.
And it's, like, the first time you're gonna get, like, so many eyes on you.
Like, sometimes, you know, people who debut... do debut streams or, like, join a company and do a debut stream.
They never had the... this is, like, the most they've ever got in their entire lives.
So, it's so nerve-wracking.
I remember when I was, like, so fucking nervous and my voice was shaking.
And I was just like...
Grapes are great.
I like cotton...
Okay, the cotton candy grapes are really good.
Wait, is she actually a rapper?
I... I could... I could...
I thought... I thought...
I thought that was a joke.
I'm sorry!
I didn't think she was actually... she was actually a rapper.
I thought she was... I thought that was, like, the joke part.
I couldn't tell!
I couldn't listen to the lyrics!
Wait, that was her narrating?
Wait, what?
Oh my god, that was her narrating!
That's actually... that's actually talented.
Damn.
I can do three voices.
This.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Yeah, that sounded so different.
All Toki all the time.
Who was that Toki?
For free?
Oh my god, this should have been, like...
Paid.
I can't believe they paid me for this!
Wow!
And I... I got paid for this.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
They paid you for fee!
Paid to look at me!
People will kill to be in my position!
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Why couldn't it be me?
Hey!
Mismatched accessories...
is a fucking...
staple...
in VTuber culture.
I have no idea why.
I think it's like one of the ways where...
I mean, I've mismatched socks too.
Mismatched tights.
But it's like...
It's like a staple in VTuber design.
I think it's like a way to be more unique.
Well, most of the mismatch you don't even see anyway!
Because you only see the fucking...
I'm symmetrical other than my bow tie...
My bows here.
Like, holy shit.
It's so fluid for something we can't see.
For like 99% of the stream.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
A lot of the...
A lot of like the creative aesthetic stuff...
Like, we don't even see it 99% of the time.
Because it's usually up on the shoulders and up.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
The arms are so fluid.
So flowing.
Whoa!
It burns off?
That's a waste of...
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
The taxpayers paid for that uniform!
Okay, the flame burning off the clothes was actually pretty cool.
Oh my god, it burns back?
This...
This goes against the laws of physics.
Who is she?
Fuck the taxpayers, I guess.
Damn.
What's the proper VTuber thing?
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Is she gonna have an angy face?
I can do that.
Say that again.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Oh no, that's a...
You know, that's...
That's a part of her skin suit.
This is like the one time you see me do an angry face.
Cause I'm just happy all the time.
Or just, like, fanatic.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, I wanna be able to do that!
I can't do that!
Gotta use Photoshop!
Yeah, that face is good.
That one's nice.
I like that her lore video did not take herself seriously.
Cause I'm, like, really tired of very...
Like, I don't know!
I feel like very serious lore videos...
There's, like, been so many...
I feel like it's been, like, overdone now.
That people just sort of, like, gloss over it these days.
Because after the debut, they're like, I am the demon from hell.
And, like, trauma dump, trauma dump.
But now, I'm here VTubing.
And then, after the lore video...
Of the very super serious lore video...
It's like...
It's like none of that existed.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
And, like, after the lore video, it's just like, Anyway, I love Hello Kitty.
And everything is okay now.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
I rather just, like...
I don't know.
I think, like...
Nowadays, it's definitely much more interesting...
To have your lore develop in real time.
So that, like...
Instead of, like, giving you all the lore at once...
Um...
It's more so, like, you build on your lore.
Like, every couple of streams...
Like, every, like...
Every, like, stream or so...
There's, like, something new you fucking made up.
Or, no, actually, it's real.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
To build up, like, bits of your lore...
You slowly add on to it.
And then...
It's real, though.
Because it's my life.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Community...
Community lore, you know?
And then...
Uh...
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
And then...
And after you, like...
And then, like, you know...
And it also gives these fans...
Like, up to interpretation for fans.
That they can, like, come up with stuff.
To...
Oh, wait!
She has a bald toggle.
I like how the hat is just, like...
Uh...
Defying physics right now.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Do you have an origin lore?
I'm a tomato.
In a skin suit.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
That's all you need to know.
Hey, Bree did the rigging!
I know her!
Can I take off my hat?
Bro, it's a fucking skin suit.
It's literally sewed into my skin.
Into my human skin.
Can you remember your skin?
Yeah, of course!
It's a skin suit.
For a reason.
What's a stinger?
It's a transition.
I have stingers, but I keep forgetting to use them.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
I've just been so busy!
I'm sorry!
It was a gift, too, from my dragoons, but I keep forgetting to set it up!
People are like, wait a minute, she does!
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Like your new PC!
Professional, I am.
I'm pretty professional.
I feel like the most professional you'll ever be is during your debut.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
And then after all, after preparing everything for your debut, and then, like, during the debut stream, you're like, it's over.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Fun facts about Encore.
Oh, but the rest of the girls in the group.
I heard, like, they're, uh...
Well, I mean, like, they're all, like, past Vtubers that joined in.
But, like, Anya is, like, uh...
Is, like, one of the ones that had, like, a complete rehaul of the group.
Of everything.
Are those, like, INFP?
Are those, like...
Oh, that's, like, the personality test.
They're, like, low-key a scam.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha
-ha -ha!
You base off your entire...
Like, if you get...
See, find out your personality traits as, like, those letters.
And you base off your entire personality on these traits.
It's...
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Ha -ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
I don't know.
I just find them a scam.
I don't think it's...
I...
I don't think, like...
Like...
Like, these types of letters can, like, basically describe your entire personality.
It's, like, how intelligent IQ tests are a scam.
Because IQ tests don't actually, like...
IQ tests that you take on the internet is a fucking scam.
Oh, hey, Hades, too!
I did, and I think it's pretty accurate.
I think it's because, like, it's more so of, like, biases.
Because it's, like, when you...
You know, it's, like, astrology.
When you see...
When you're, like, oh, what's my...
What's my zodiac sign?
And then you read the zodiac prediction and the personality.
And you're, like, wait, that's me!
That's how I feel, like, uh...
That's how I feel about, like, personality tests.
Like, you read the personality test.
And you're, like, wait, that's me!
Because, like, you know, you're, like, oh, that's totally me, you know?
It's just...
I feel like it's just really broad.
Yeah, confirmation bias.
There's just, like, way too many, like, statements in a personality test.
Like, in, like, those, like, personality tests.
That, like, at least one of them would match you.
Sounds like what a Libra would say.
Joke's on you.
I'm not a Libra.
Wait, has it been an hour already?
Wait, are the debuts 30 minutes?
Wait, what?
Is she going to sleep?
There's no way it's over.
She's, like, at her schedule.
Or did she just go too fast?
Wait, are they actually 30 minutes?
She's so cool.
I think 30 minutes is, like, optimal.
I think, like, 30 to 40 minutes is a good balance.
Because when a debut stream is way too long, it just drags on too much.
And then, like, you sort of... it loses the hype IMO.
This is my own opinion.
But I think 30 to 40 minutes is, like, actually a good balance.
Yeah, it stops a lot of dead air, too.
Yeah.
2.0 is where you want to go, like, more...
Where you go more in-depth in things.
She's probably on a lot of energy drinks.
To be fair, that's really common.
Because a lot of people, before their debut, they're, like, so nervous.
And, like, they couldn't sleep and stuff like that.
So it makes sense that, like, you know, you have to have an energy drink on.
Like, a lot of famous VTubers had to, for their very first debut, would be, like, on a shitload of caffeine.
Wait,
I know how to spell crayon.
Oh my god, finally I'm smarter than somebody.
Yeah, C-R-A-Y-O-N.
Toki's been too real.
Wait, wait, why?
The pause.
Why did you pause?
Because I'm watching a debut!
Like, what do you mean, why did I pause?
We're doing a watch-along.
We're fucking multitasking right now.
Oh shit, okay, the isolation is fucking sick, though.
The first pause of the whole stream.
Oh shit, is that the...
Is that the...
Oh, that's the...
The genmates.
That's cute.
The animation's really cute.
I love it.
Is her genmates a deer?
No, she was gonna eat a deer.
Actually, I was interested... I hope Anya sings more.
Actually, I was interested in seeing, like, her... more of her singing.
Since they're, like, idol.
You know, like, they're, like, the idol idol.
Uh...
The, uh...
Idol group?
Maybe she'll sing at the end.
Oh, she, like...
She's, like...
What was it called?
There's, like, a particular name, like, kawaii rap.
I swear, like, there's a name for that type of rapping.
Cause it's, like, a Gatmoe with the voice and the rap style.
I assume, like, that's, like, her rap style from the white boy rap that we heard.
I assume that's it.
Alright, let's see your cover.
I mean...
To be fair, I did not realize that her... the debut streams are, like, 30 minutes each.
Because, like...
Uh...
Idol EN paid for an hour.
So, you know, it's fair that I listened to your cover, too.
You know, you get your money's worth.
Guys, I don't scam people.
You get your money's worth.
Kat, thank you for the tier 1 resub for two months in a row!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
That ending screen.
Seems so familiar.
Is there a cover out?
And she did say she's gonna rate it into her cover video.
She did say that.
Alright, let's see.
Anya.
Alright.
Oh, yeah!
2.35!
Okay, there it is.
Uh...
If my mod can pin her cover...
Her cover into...
Wait, is this, like...
It's a cover video.
My song knows what you did in the dark.
Wait, what...
What kind of song is that?
Wait, is this Fall Out Boy?
Oh, shit!
This is Fall Out Boy!
Alright.
Oh my god.
Fall Out Boy.
I'm not used to seeing English songs being sung by Vtubers.
Especially...
Even if they're, like, part of an EN company.
I'm just...
I'm never used to seeing that, you know?
Alright.
So, uh...
Can my mod pin the...
Uh, yeah.
Can you pin that, mod?
Is there another debut?
I unfortunately don't have time to watch the second and third debut.
Uh...
Because, uh...
Like I said, I have my own announcement later on today.
So, like...
I need to, like, set up the overlays and everything.
So...
So, unfortunately...
Unfortunately, I won't be able to watch the second and third.
Alright.
Because I know, like...
After...
Whoa!
Okay.
That always catches me off guard.
Whenever they do the...
The whole...
Um...
The whole, like...
Like, the fucking premiere.
For the premiere stuff, I always choose, like, the...
The...
The quietest one.
Because...
The...
I don't understand.
I don't understand why, like, the premiere videos that you choose...
For your...
For, like...
That you choose, it's so fucking loud.
Like, the countdown stuff is actually crazy loud.
Um...
And, like...
I...
I always try to choose the quiet...
Like, the...
The...
The the...
Not -Suprising...
Countdowns.
Just because the volume balancing for these is, like, actually...
Terrible.
Like, you can't even balance it too...
So wake you up.
Yeah?
I mean, like...
The reason why I can't choose the second and third is also because, like...
It's also because, like...
Um...
There's, like, a delay in between debuts.
And, by the time the second one comes up...
I won't have time...
It was actually interesting to watch a debut again.
I have not watched a full debut, like I would watch like highlights of debuts, but I haven't watched a full debut live in a very long time.
Because I feel like a person's personality and how they are streaming wise, you don't see that in debut.
And I like that's why like for me, like I feel like usually I just watch their other streams after their debut, just to like see what they are like as a person or like as a VTuber.
So it was interesting to watch again.
Oh, it's this song!
I did not know the title of this song.
Yeah, it's just the pilot.
I actually like this song.
She's pretty good.
I'm up, up, up.
Oh my gosh, this is like the type of song that you want to sing along to.
Yeah, she's really good.
The instrumental is really nice too.
I'm always so jealous of people that can sing.
I wish my vocal cords can do that.
What do you mean?
You guys, guys, this is just a lot of copium right now.
You cannot say I can sing just like this.
Yeah.
This is like fucking pure, like actual talent.
I'm up, up, up.
Light him up, up, up.
Fire.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Well, oh, oh, oh.
oh, oh, oh, oh.
I would love to hear more of her rapping though.
Because like that's her special.
Like, specialized.
I think it's really smart.
I assume the other two are-are like main singers.
And then they're-Anya's like the rapper of the group.
Which makes sense because a lot of idol groups now.
It's like two, like you know.
You have at least one rapper.
To do like the rap break.
People say I can rap, but it's just a spoken word for me.
I don't even know if I can actually or if people are just being nice.
I have no idea if I can actually rap or if people are just being nice to me.
She's the roller player of the trio.
That was fun.
I really enjoyed...
Like I said, it's been so long since I watched the actual debut live.
Not just like highlights and stuff.
So it was really interesting.
I think... I actually would love to hear more of her rapping.
Just because it's like her specialty.
But like you can tell that...
She has...
Like her vocal range is insane.
You can tell.
Just from the fact that the fucking...
You know, the intro video that she did.
The intro video that she did there.
Where she like fucking went from like...
I guess like low voice to like high pitch was like insane.
I was like, oh my gosh, I can't do that.
Yeah, the watch mojo.
It's interesting to see that she didn't list her...
Her like debut is very unconventional.
In a way that, you know...
Like usually the...
You know, the fucking default template is...
Is like, you know...
What was the default template?
Like likes, dislikes, favorite games, stuff like that.
Like she didn't go that route.
It was more so of just shitposting.
Which is nice to see sometimes.
Because...
I don't know.
As a fellow shitposter...
Um...
It's nice to see like...
Like someone trying to do something different.
Um...
It adds more variety.
You know, you just don't expect it type deal.
It's like, oh...
They do something that you don't expect.
So, I guess it keeps you on the toes.
And stuff like that.
Yeah, it's like...
Uh...
Yeah, she only puts like...
Yeah, but we don't know her game choices.
Like what is like...
Type of games that she might like.
Or like her favorite...
Like her favorite games.
Stuff like that.
Um...
I guess it's like something we find out.
I guess it also makes you want to watch...
Debut 2.0.
So you can...
I guess it's a nice like...
Bait too.
To like bait you into watching...
Debut 2.0.
Unless it's like the newest meta.
Like I said, I haven't watched fucking debut streams in a long ass time.
But like in debut 2.0...
You actually like know more about the person.
Regarding like...
Their specific interests.
So if she...
Like people would be like...
Oh yeah.
Um...
I really liked watching her debut video.
But what does she actually do?
I guess I'll have to watch...
Debut 2.0.
To find out...
What her like...
Other interests are.
Um...
So it was pretty interesting.
Her assets are...
Uh...
I've...
Oh my god.
Her fucking like...
Live...
Subtitles stuff.
Was pretty cool.
But I feel like...
If I try to get one of those live subtitles...
Checking it can never translate what I'm saying.
Hahaha.
I don't know.
Haha.
It'll just be like...
70% laughing.
Last time...
That was just be like...
Haha.
Hahaha.
Yeah.
You have to speak like...
Very clearly.
Annunciate.
That is so...
True.
And...
We all know.
That is something...
I do not do.
Hahaha.
Haha.
We have a mush mouth for a reason, but yeah, very interesting debut so far, definitely like not the usual, the usual type of debuts you see for like the debut templates and stuff.
So it's always really nice to see something different.
And just to be like, you know, surprised about like what it is, like surprised and like not knowing what you're going to see next in a debut.
So, and she is clearly a very talented singer.
I think the one thing, like I said before, I think the one thing I would love to see was just more rapping, just because it's her speciality.
Like I know like the white boy rap was like a shitpost, but it was another shitpost.
But I would definitely love to see like actual, like actual rap.
Like rapping from her.
I guess we'll see it later.
We'll see it more of that later.
Since, honestly, I will not be surprised.
I will not be surprised if she has a, if the group has a debut song together.
But if they don't, then like, well, I was wrong.
But if they do have one, then it's like, you know, the template.
They're the singer group.
They should, I feel like.
I feel like they should since they're the singing group, right?
Like it seems like something, the debut group song meta.
Yeah, it's like meta now.
Like the debut group song.
Or listed the debut song of the three members.
Yeah.
So maybe we'll definitely hear more of her rapping in there since it's like singer, singer, rapper.
I mean, it's a very smart choice.
Cause like concerts make so much money.
I feel like concerts in general is like one of the biggest money makers for like VTubers.
Because like for one, it's less...
What's the word?
There's less of a budget going in, setting up a concert for VTubers versus setting up a concert for like real people.
Toki, you can't say that.
VTubers are just as real.
You're right.
Sorry.
I'm...
I honestly think like...
I think like budget cost-wise, like logistical...
Yeah, fewer logistical expenses.
Okay, here are some logistical expenses a VTuber concert does not have to worry about.
Food.
It's like...
Yeah, if it's...
Like...
Anyway, or like not...
Sorry, I meant like non-3D stuff.
Obviously 3D stuff.
Yes.
3D stuff.
Food.
But like I feel like logistic-wise, definitely IMO like a VTuber con...
Like also like special effects.
You know, when you do like special effects, you know, like pyrotechnics or whatever.
Like when you go to like an IRL concert, all that stuff.
And then cleaning the stage.
And everything.
Like you don't have to worry about that because it's all on a screen.
And then like, you know, like fucking...
Oh, we need like fire coming up behind the VTuber.
Don't worry.
I got it in post.
Click, click, click.
Oh, yeah.
And also security.
You're right.
Explosions behind.
Don't worry.
Let me download real quick on the Unity store.
Insert fire gift.
Don't worry.
Let me download a fucking fireworks on the Unity store real quick.
And then click and drag.
Yeah.
Thank you again.
Thank you again to Idle Union for sponsoring me to do an official...
An official watch along.
It was really exciting.
I know like there has been like a lot of companies are wondering, will I do more official watch alongs in the future?
It really depends.
I guess like the offer.
Idle Union was like the first one to offer to me.
So then obviously and then like obviously like I saw the amount and then because it is sponsored.
And I was like, yeah, fuck it.
I'll take it.
Because like I'm just giving me a lot of expenses for me.
In the future regarding like projects and like stuff for you guys.
So I was like, you know, I'll take it to reinvest in the channel.
Like giving a new new talents some publicity.
And then I like we all win.
We all win.
But it really depends on the offer.
And obviously I won't be taking all saying yes to every offer.
But it really depends.
But yes, thank you guys so much.
Anyway, we'll go back to prepping for my announcement stream.
Thank you everybody for watching and this watch along as always.
If you're new here, I have a special announcement on YouTube.
So please check me out over on YouTube.
And also you want to know when I stream on Twitch.
Follow me on Twitter because that's usually where I post announcements of when I stream on Twitch.
Especially if it's like out of nowhere like this like this one like a gorilla stream type deal.
And you want to support me.
If you have any other means feel free to check out my merch.
We are currently trying to send out the merch by like not all of the merch.
But we're slowly trickling in like sending out orders for debut merch starting next week.
So please look forward to that.
Like obviously like not it.
There's a lot.
Trickling in.
Anyway.
So I really apologize if it's taking a while.
But yes as always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Stay up a little longer.
Because we do have a special announcement later today.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.